elle trône un séjour n'est pas parce que
nos gars plein d'activités dans le sport
qu'on n'a pas baissé on a fait dieu de
tir au pistolet et on a fait de la
course
ça fait du bien au corps ici c'est
amusant si tous les dlc la génération
2024 ces jeunes vont vivre dans trois
ans les jeux olympiques en france c'est
pour faire monter l'engouement saint
quentin en yvelines a convié cinq cents
élèves de 18 collèges de l'agglomération
au golf national ce mercredi 23 juin une
trentaine d'ateliers au programme pour
découvrir les disciplines olympiques et
paralympiques
c'est une manière très importante de
permettre aux enfants de s'accaparer les
jeux olympiques et les valeurs de
l'olympisme qui sont très très
importante les valeurs du sport
mais la peur de l'olympisme tout
particulièrement si j'étais entre les
bras
pratiquement toute sa place cette
journée était aussi l'occasion pour ces
jeunes de faire la connaissance de
sportive de haut niveau parmi les
athlètes présents l'ancien handballeur
olivier girault capitaine de l'équipe de
france championne du monde en 2001 et
médaillé d'or aux jo de pékin en 2008
moi petit c'est comme ça aussi que j'ai
évolué j'aurais voulu que des champions
qu'on réussit qui ont réussi reviennent
transmettent c'est un plaisir de
devenir transmettent et il ya plein de
gamins plein d'éducateurs plein de
bénévoles voilà tout l'écosystème du
sport ai réunis c'est une super
initiative donc obligatoire d'être
présent à la mi journée les jeunes ont
pu assister à des démonstrations du
tumbling avec la présence d'axel duriez
du club des clayes-sous-bois double
champion du monde des 13 14 ans bmx flat
football freestyle ou encore breakdance
la discipline sera olympique en 2024
c'est important de la faire connaître
d'ici là pour carlotta dudek
à 19 ans elle rêve de participer aux jo
de paris ça permet un petit peu d'avoir
un premier contact avec nous et du coup
nous ensuite on va pouvoir échanger avec
leurs de noriko la fin des mouvements
donc nous c'est tout ce qu'on aime
pouvoir leur montrer leur apprendre et
et aille avant leur bonne humeur et tout
leur intérêt ou toit et un belge
saint quentin en yvelines accueillera
cinq épreuves des jo en 2024 au golf et
vélodrome nationale et sur la colline
d'elancourt rendez vous donné dès
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
journée au nord